les employés sont très en colère et pour
cause la fermeture représente le
licenciement de plus de 3000 personnes
et la destruction de plus de 25000
emplois en direct nissan a décidé de
fermer son site catalan pour
redistribuer la production l'usiné de
barcelone concentrer à elle seule 10% de
la production européenne
il s'agit donc d'un véritable coup dur
pour l'emploi en catalogne
la mairie de barcelone s'est opposé à
cette fermeture elle a d'ailleurs
rappelé que l'entreprise a touché de
l'argent public
en échange de son engagement à un
conserver son activité en catalogne
alors la décision est sur le tapis
depuis plusieurs mois mais cette
fermeture tombe très mal en pleine crise
du coc vide 19 l'espagne craint une
crise économique et surtout que le cas
de nissan soit le premier d'une longue
liste
une nouvelle qui a laissé les samariens
catalan de nissan sous le chaque écoute
et nous parlons d'environ 25000 famille
entre les emplois directs et les sous
traitants
donc cette décision a un important coup
porté à ces familles à l'économie
espagnole
donc nous les employés nous allons tout
tenter jusqu'à la fin c'est clair c'est
un coup dur pour notre famille nous
travaillons dans une usine avec mon mari
nous avons deux filles la plus grande
commence le lycée elle à ses projets
d'avenir et avec la situation actuelle
est le co vide qui n'aide pas imaginer
un nouvel avenir c'est difficile
replanter sont photographiés ensemble
votre enseigne c'est la presse a mené
cela fait 32 ans que je travaille pour
s'être entreprises pour nissan mais ce
n'est pas juste moi je pense que ce
n'est pas juste le côté individuel de
l'affection que tu peux avoir pour l'
usine mais la répercussion que cela peut
avoir pour vingt-cinq mille travailleurs
c'est cela le gros problème et c'est
pour cela que nous luttons ça le
problème
il est en revanche l'autre